Speaker 1: Let's start today with the economy.
Is a massive recession coming? It's question
one. Question two is. If so or if not, what,
if anything, should you or I or anybody else
be doing about it? We're seeing increasingly
hyperbolic predictions about just a massive
global and American recession coming. Is one
coming? I have no idea. If you're waiting for
me to give my opinion, I have absolutely no idea
whether a massive recession is coming. But really,
neither does anybody else. So let's talk through
it and explain. First of all, as a general
reality, humans aren't good at making
economic predictions, which are just
not good. And secondly, when there are so many
predictions floating around, someone is predicting
everything. Somebody is bound to be right just by
chance. So you've got all the people predicting a
recession in a week and then in a month and then
in six months and over the next 12 to 18 months,
over the next two years or no recession, it's
all going to be great. Somebody is bound to get
it right just by chance and by the fact
that we have 330 million people in the
United States, many of whom are making economic
predictions. That's number two. Number three,
predicting doom and gloom and recessions generally
gets more clicks and gets you invited onto more
television programs and gets more articles
written about your predictions. So it's
important to understand the bias to sensationalism
and zooming out and saying, hey, you know what?
I don't know what's going to happen over
the next two years, but over the next 30,
the market will probably return an average of
7% per year like it always has. That's not a
particularly titillating and exciting prediction,
and that's not going to get you booked on too many
television programs. So that's another important
thing to understand the bias to sensationalism and
a bias to negative predictions. And then number
four, and this may be the most important thing,
unless something changes with the way our
economy works, there's always a recession coming
eventually. So if you predict a recession for
long enough or over a long enough period of time,
at some point you're going to be right.
Because unless something changes and we have
no more recessions. And again, as we've talked
about before, recessions are sort of part of
a capitalist economy. If you keep predicting
recessions, at some point you're going to be
right. Now, let's get into the specifics. There
are people who have been predicting a recession,
a massive recession since 2012, since 2014, since
2016. And the truth is that the economy has been
pretty good for most of that time. We had this
COVID collapse, which lasted like six weeks,
markets collapsing, unemployment rate increasing,
and then it recovered relatively quickly. They've
been wrong. But if they keep predicting it,
at some point, they might end up being right.
So now let's get to a question about numbers and
data. Are there good or accurate predictors of
when a recession is coming? If we look back in
history and the answer is there are a handful
of indicators that do indeed seem to point
to the economy being, quote, good or, quote,
bad. And these are terms that don't really mean
anything unless we define them a little bit
better. So what can we say about the indicators?
The first thing is, when you start seeing a steady
rise in job losses and a surge in the unemployment
rate, that can be a good indicator of a coming
recession. Now, we don't have that at this point
in time. If we look at job creation, you see that
it actually looks pretty good. You see, if you're
looking at the screen here, on the left side of
your screen is the unemployment rate. And on
the right side of the screen is job creation. We
had a big spike in the unemployment rate during
the beginning of COVID and we had a big drop in
payrolls at the at that exact same time. And
then since then, we've seen the unemployment
rate go down and remain pretty low and we've
seen payrolls increase and remain, quite frankly,
quite high. Now, is it possible is it possible
that you would see a recession despite a solid
employment situation? Anything is possible, but
it's not the way it tends to go historically.
I think I had one other chart here. Yes. So this
is just a little bit of a more zoomed in look at
the unemployment rate. And as you can see, if
you go back a long way, there's been sort of
like this range and we're well within the range
that we've seen for many, many decades at this
point in time. Okay. So what other indicators
could we look at that might signal? All that
a recession is coming while another one is
a decline in GDP. And when you look at GDP,
you do see that in that start of 2020, there's
this little decline in it. And it's little,
historically speaking, but it was significant at
the time. And you see that real GDP went down and
then it has gone relatively back to normal and
increased. And there were a couple little dips
there, but GDP really looks pretty unremarkable.
So that's not an indicator historically that
a recession is coming. Another indicator that
historically has been sometimes predictive of
a recession is retail sales. And when you look at
retail sales and in fact, we can look at it maybe
over a 25 year period or even a ten year period,
you see that retail sales are actually pretty
okay year over year. There was this big decline.
Again, there's so much of this mirroring what was
going on with COVID, very large decline in retail
sales at the beginning of 2020 March-April. And
then there was this very big increase. Looks
like roughly what exactly was that? That was
sort of like middle of 2021. And retail sales
are pretty unremarkable. So we're just not seeing
the indicators that are normally predictive of a
recession signal that a recession is coming. Now,
what are the differences? The differences
are. Inflation, although it is declining
and I believe will continue to decline, has been
high, historically high for about a year or even
a little bit more. Could that alone, even in the
context of all of these other indicators looking
fine, could that maybe point to a recession?
Maybe. But again, it's if things are changing,
if the circumstances that point to a recession are
different now than they were in the past. So we'll
we're going to have to wait and see. Now, a really
important thing to think about at the individual
level is what should you be doing? What should
I be doing? What should individuals be doing?
If we believe a recession is coming to be best
prepared there really the things that we should
be doing all the time. So first and foremost, do
you have an emergency fund? When we think about an
emergency fund, we're usually talking about $1,000
so that if an unexpected expense above and beyond
your normal monthly expenses comes up, you don't
have to put it on a high interest credit card or
borrow money. Thousand dollar emergency fund if
you don't have it. In particular, if you think a
recession is coming, you should work to establish
that number to understand your health insurance
limits so that, you know, if I have unexpected
medical bills and medical bills are often
unexpected. What is the most that I might have to
go out of pocket? So this means understanding your
deductible and understanding your maximum out of
pocket. Number three, paying down high interest
debt for two reasons. Number one, paying 15
20% interest on a credit card is a very bad
financial aid. That's an extraordinarily high
interest rate. And if you can avoid paying that,
you want to avoid paying that. And number two, on
the high interest debt, if you believe a recession
is or may be coming, and if you want to have as
much financial flexibility as possible, you want
to have credit available on those credit cards.
And every dollar you can pay off frees up a dollar
if indeed you had no choice but to start charging
things in a future recession. And the number four
try to establish that 4 to 6 month reserve
of monthly expenses. So in an ideal world,
you would figure out what are my monthly expenses?
You would multiply by four or ideally six, or if
you want to be, you know, have an extra cushion.
And it's not possible for many people buy nine and
have somewhere between four and six or even nine
months of expenses in the bank. So if your income
went to zero for that period of time, you would
still be able to pay your monthly expenses. This
is the type of stuff we typically talk about on
the Pacman Finance Channel. So if any of this is
interesting, we have this whole other channel,
you can find it at YouTube.com, slash, Pacman,
finance. And if you go through the topics
we've covered, you see that most of the
things I've mentioned are listed as individual
videos, paying off debt, building a budget,
etc., etc. So check that out at YouTube.com
slash Pacman finance if it is interesting to you